what would Spider-Man be like if he
existed in our universe probably on
trial for murder I'm so sorry Peter but
you're good for murder after the Honest
Trailer click the link in the
description to watch a real lawyer break
down his many many crimes I told you it
was a menace the falling trailer is
rated s for spoilers
[Music]
Marvel has done the Multiverse to death
DC had their way with its corpse
now the RC Cola movie studios wants a
turn and the third time's the charm
because holy sh they turned out a
masterpiece
across the spider-verse
scrap in for the best movie to watch
when your ADHD medication runs dry where
even the logo should come with a seizure
warning Phil with so much visual energy
it's impossible to get bored and even
the urge to check Twitter I mean X is
fed by them posting directly into the
movie in such a detailed work of art
you'll wonder how the animators had time
to see their families oh they didn't and
they're only halfway done cool cool cool
cool almost got to enjoy something for a
minute there thanks
Miles Morales is back for a second time
to introduce himself a bunch more times
okay let's do this one last time
my name is Miles Morales my name
Miles Morales I'm Miles Morales when
he's not having someone else introduce
him his name is Miles Morales watch
Miles Hit That Awkward stage where he
looks like a Spider-Man but sounds like
his spider eggs haven't quite dropped
yet
he'll stretches spandex alongside spider
Gwen this angst machine will friend zone
you to death I never really made another
friend after that in every other
Universe it doesn't end well
and if you couldn't tell by her haircut
she's got problems okay in this line of
work you always wind up a solo act in
fact it's Canon now that everyone is
somewhere on the emo Spectrum
[Music]
no matter what I do someone always
thinks I'm blowing it so
I can't talk right now
thinking about my past and no one is
more in their feelings than Miguel
O'Hara A combustible mix of Latino
smolder and Irish rage
I'll worry about spot Oscar Isaac
continues his run of impeccably asked
characters proving that he's learned a
lot since the last time he was a comic
book villain
to the point where the movie just kind
of forgot about the awesome bad guy they
spent the first half setting up I'm from
your past
one year ago oh come on where did the
spot go I don't care about the Huey
versus Riley thing they set up he was
spot holder Phil the first spider burst
introduced us to a few wild variants now
meet literally everyone else
as an entire cosmology of Freaks and
Geeks gets dumped onto the screen at
once in an eye-popping homage to every
spider thing you recognize from every
other spider thing
set for some reason it defies the logic
of space-time good taste and capitalism
Japanese Spider-Man
look I didn't go frame by frame so maybe
he's in the background but part two
better LED to kuya shine
[Applause]
enjoy the first Spider-Man movie to
fully explore their love and admiration
for the police you're a good cop done
this mask is my badge we're miles has a
cop dad and a famous cop voicing his mom
Gwen is a cop dad and most every spider
person signed up to be a time cop I lead
an elite Strike Force dedicated to the
security of the Multiverse in a story
about how miles true calling is to back
the blue even when it means breaking the
universe
you disrupted a cannon event they're all
just out there trying their best you
know oh this is why nobody likes us man
it's a it's actually because of all the
uh no politics at the dinner table fine
whatever Hobie gets it taking a crap on
the establishment I salute you sorry one
more time taking a crap on the
establishment I salute you so Feast your
eyes on the best cartoon produced under
the most awful conditions since Walt
Disney locked 30 slaves in a vault and
said don't come out until Cinderella's
done that uses animation not just a
surprise and Delight but to genuinely
Advance the storytelling that truly
delivers on the promise and potential of
a Multiverse but still Candice escape
the curse of modern franchise movie
making a big dumb floating head looking
through a portal excuse me sorry to bug
you I know you're busy sorry can I have
some gum
can you see me uh floating hit alert
story
my little Spidey Emily twippenson I got
2099 problems kilometers Morales another
Bagel Multiverse origin story you hit me
with a bagel
I got bored one day when I put
everything on a bagel
everything I'm rooting for everybody
around Spiderman e Quran hair Brian
Tyree daddy her name is Rio she's the
mama Spiderman all audiences at this
point you say the fate of the Multiverse
and my brain dies and no one man should
be also prouler
Lo-Fi hip-hop beats to fight too
kind of sad Rachel Dratch probably gets
more residuals from this than Steve
ditko's entire state
still want more spider stuff watch a
real lawyer break down the crimes of
Spider-Man next if I had somebody that
came in and said that they were from the
Multiverse I am going to have to get
them psychologically evaluated click the
Box on the right to watch now
nah I'm a do my own thing I got the
results of the test back I definitely
have epic boys nothing for five whole
seconds
pocket sand